hello everyone in this video we are
going to discuss the important
personality traits which are absolutely
essential for success in phd now there
are a bunch of different personality
traits but i am going to focus my
attention on three different categories
the first category is
your ability to take criticism your
openness to it your resilience and your
adaptability the second category is to
do with your courage and independence of
thought and the third category is your
selfishness very surprisingly and your
street smartness
now these ideas and opinions i have
developed over the years not through my
own but in discussion with other
professors with other students
and i would like to extend a special
thanks to my own phd supervisor
professor shuman chakravarti
by discussion with whom i have
developed a majority of these ideas and
a special thanks to my postdoc advisors
also so without further ado let's get
into this personality traits
the first category is your openness to
criticism your
resilience and your adaptability
now there are very few absolute truths
in this world and one of them is that if
you are not open to criticism during
your phd then you are not going to be
successful it is as black and white as
that
now the there can be different sources
of criticism during your phd but the
most important and the most common
source will be your supervisor himself
now
if you discuss with different phd
students you will hear a
lot of different ways in which the
supervisor may criticize but you can
rest assured that the most common source
of criticism will be on the writing
aspect
so what usually happens is that a phd
student comes along uh does the research
work and then uh in the first year maybe
in the second year writes up the first
manuscript and after a lot of effort may
be spread over weeks or months submits
the first manuscript with a phd with a
lot of pride in his heart
a couple of weeks later the supervisor
comes back with the manuscript filled
with red marks comments this and that
and when this student sees his almost a
work of art being completely cut apart
like this
like these are like this edge each red
mark
on the on the manuscript feels like a
stab wound on his heart okay it is as
painful as that so it's almost like an
existential crisis
but
you have to take this okay please do not
think that uh the supervisor is uh
taking it out on you on some kind of a
personal level it is absolutely nothing
like that it is only his or her effort
to help you improve he himself has gone
through this very same stage at one
point in his life a big problem that is
faced on this account is by the academic
superstars from the undergraduate days
okay so these are the kinds of students
who have always been
heaped with praises maybe even from
their school days and when they face
this sort of a criticism on their work
they cannot take it okay but you have to
understand that you have to have to take
this and improve yourself based on these
comments
and remarks from your supervisor the
next source of criticism is of course
every student has to face this
from the reviewers of their work so
after a paper has been submitted for
review after work has been submitted for
review it comes back from the reviewers
and sometimes it can be a little bit
spiteful okay because uh what happens
mostly is that it's a
single blind kind of review so you never
get to know the names of the reviewers
and sometimes they can get a little bit
spiteful and
it seems like a total and absolute
criticism of your work so what i say to
all my students is that wait for a day
or two to cool off before responding to
the reviewer's comments
okay now if the reviewer has been little
bit unprofessional and just said some
arbitrary things
i would say it is just like a social
problem to manage your emotions and
respond but it is not that difficult a
situation the more difficult situation
is when the reviewers have been actually
professional about it respectful but
they have pointed out certain things
which you know in your heart are
actually correct so you have made a
mistake and all that you can do is go
back to the drawing board start from
square one and do everything all over
again maybe redo the simulations maybe
redo the experiments maybe justify the
simplifying assumptions that you had
taken that you had begun your
mathematical modeling with this is the
more difficult work and this is where
you need a lot of resilience a lot of
patience to actually power through this
work
and what happens is that sometimes
when the review comes back you have
already started another piece of work
and that piece of work may be going on
absolutely fine and you want to your
every fiber of your being wants to go
back to that work continue that work but
the
the situation demands that you have to
drop that work and focus your attention
on this uh responding to the reverse
work okay so it's a it's an emotional
roller coaster kind of thing but you
have to be resilient enough and
adaptable enough to undo this thing
please also do not forget like i had
mentioned in my earlier video that
while all of this is going on uh you can
understand that it takes a lot of time
sometimes days will turn to weeks weeks
will turn to months before you can
actually come up with a cogent uh and
coherent response to the reviewer's
comments what will happen is that
simultaneously you will get some kind of
comments while uh phone phone calls with
your family that when you are getting
married and this kind of
various kinds of disturbing kind of
things so it's very very important and
difficult also to to keep your cool
in these trying times okay so you have
to be extremely emotionally stable
level-headed to handle these kinds of
things okay so not just open to
criticism but also resilient truly
resilient and adaptable
the next category the number two
category is courage and independence of
thought in the first one or two years it
is quite natural that your supervisor
will do a little bit of hand holding
will help you guide you by instructing
you what to read what to do next but
please note that this is not the actual
relationship between a phd student and
his supervisor
because this is more like a boss
instructing his worker to do certain
things
and
the sooner that you can get out you can
transition from this worker mode of
operation to a real researcher mode of
operation the better it is for you
so what you have to actually do is to go
out and explore the domain on your own
you have to read you have to actually
find out the latest and most important
papers
that are relevant for your work read
them up on your own identify the gap
that is there and then you have to
bring out
come up yourself with fresh and new
ideas that you can probably implement on
your own and then you have to pitch
those ideas to your supervisor so the
supervisor's job will ultimately reduce
in this ideal scenario to think and
guide you on what could be a possible
roadmap based on the ideas that you have
generated
now this mode of operation this
independent researcher mode of operation
is not something which comes naturally
to us we have been brought up in such a
fashion that
we are very obedient and subservient in
our mentality okay
we like to be told what to do next we
have a certain passivity in our nature
now this kind of a behavior and
personality trait is good for world
peace but it is not good for independent
research work
okay so you have to have to force
yourself to get into this independent
researcher mode of operation and i know
that the very idea of thinking for
oneself
charting out a course of action for
oneself following through it by taking
some risk
this is
something very very difficult
you have to force yourself
and the greatest danger that you will
have to confront with is that when you
are following through based on these
ideas of your own you will also have to
live with the consequences of your own
decisions and actions
so if you think what i'm doing what i'm
saying right now seems a little bit like
an
entrepreneurial adventure uh you are
perhaps right okay so these kinds of
idea generation and are working it is a
little bit of a work like an
entrepreneur's work
the next category of personality trait
is selfishness surprisingly and a little
bit of street smartness
what do i mean by that usually the
students who join phd are the studious
types we all know this okay they're the
scholar types and
typically these are also the kinds of
students
who are the proverbial good boys and
girls imbued with the virtues which
makes them kind helpful and
compassionate but unfortunately these
are also the qualities which
breeds
a pathological need to win others
approval
and a constant desire to please everyone
around them but this kind of personality
is extremely detrimental to the success
of phd instead what i think can lead to
success in phd is a little bit of street
smartness and a healthy dose of
selfishness
let me illustrate to you what i mean
suppose you are a phd student in a
computational domain
you are in a research lab
and you are good with computers may be
good with simulations and programming
people around you know this fact
very soon inevitably what will happen is
that people will start approaching you
for help with their simulation work with
their programming people even from other
departments may approach you for help
with their work now when you extend your
help to others
it feeds into a primordial instinct to
feel needed so definitely you feel very
good about yourself you may even feel
that through this help that you are
providing you are actually augmenting
your own knowledge and skills
but remember there are only 24 hours a
day seven days a week and by investing a
non-trivial amount of your time in
helping others
are you not perhaps hampering your own
work
so this is the part where i want you to
think a little bit only about yourself i
mean that you need to start being
selfish i need you to first recognize
that your own work is the number one
priority
you also need to make it very clear to
anyone who approaches you that will be
only able to spare the time to help them
after you have completed your own work
so you see i'm not asking you to be
selfish
in the sense that you go out and
actively harm others for your own
benefit rather i am asking you to be
selfish by first thinking about a
situation where you do not help others
at the cost of harming yourself there is
a big difference between the two
however let us not stop here let us take
this one step further so what i'm saying
is that you need not turn away every
person who seeks your help what you can
do is you can selectively see
who you can really help in the sense
that instead of providing an informal
kind of help can you not perhaps
transform that informal health into a
formal collaboration you talk with your
supervisor about the idea that this
person has approached you with
ask that other person to talk with his
or her supervisor also and if it
actually turns out that there is a scope
for you to provide a meaningful and
substantial help whether it is in the
coding or the programming or whatever
simulation work then together with your
supervisor and this other person
supervisor it can be turned into formal
collaboration with the understanding
that if something meaningful something
fruitful comes out in the form of a
publication your name will be definitely
there in the author's list
remember the joker's words if you're
good at something never do it for free
so thank you very much everyone ah i
hope you enjoyed this video bye